it's crazy sometimes i'll be getting
these deals
and uh you know we'll be on the phone
and be like oh you just got this deal
over
these three nba guys and i'm like damn
i'm like getting these deals at nba guys
it's crazy to me still is
like you're getting deals that like that
they over them
so essentially instead of them getting
the deal you got the deal yeah as the
trainer
yeah yeah and uh which is which is
really cool
that was never the goal though but it
just it just happened like that um
you know i've had my own bowl of
chipotle that was cool so you could go
to chipotle
across the country and get the chris
wrigley bowl that was fire
um i had a stockx deal i have a lids
deal um when you say you have a lids do
they give you your own hat or like what
is it yeah so i
i designed like two hats that come out
across the world i
so i own color blind it's like a
clothing company so you know we made
some hats with them
uh i'm in nba 2k he's deciding to deal
with body armor which is cool
puma um we got stockx
uh wilson so i actually uh have my own
like training balls with wilson
which is fire mommy got his own
basketballs
yeah it's dope